Imagine that the farmer is looking at a plot of land that's 1,900 meters wide
and 4,000 meters long. The irrigation system makes fields with a radius of 400
meters. To save some time, I did some of the math. And hopefully you can read
from my drawing, that the first row will need 800 meters of length. To get two
rows, you'll need 800 plus 400, times the square root of 3. Meters of length.
To get three rows, you'll need 800 plus 2, times 400 times the square root of 3
meters of length. How many rows will fit on a piece of land that's 4,000 meters
long? My goal isn't to test you on geometry. Just to show an example of how to
solve a mathematical problem with Java. Try a few times, and watch the solution
carefully if it doesn't work.